whether you're an entrepreneur or just
an independent contractor guess what we
all are we all sales people so when
somebody says I'm not a salesperson I'm
an entrepreneur they don't really
understand a meaning of an entrepreneur
every entrepreneurs a salesperson so I
want you to today look at this from the
process of asking yourself which part of
the sales process do I make a mistake in
where is your leak in the sales process
of whatever your business may be where's
the leak that you have because for me
over the years every single time my
sales would drop or I would see someone
outdoing me I would always ask myself
where in the process do I have a problem
with what in the process as a challenge
I have that have to figure out a way to
improve because in reality you know
improvement in sales sales is really
about discipline and it's about details
if you are not disciplined which means
work ethic diligence follow-through all
that stuff
or you're not paying attention to the
details that we're about to get into
right now you're simply winging it and
you don't want a wing sale sales is a
lot of people made this who are sales is
guaranteed to work listen when people
tell me how to make it in sales I
guarantee you you like discipline or you
didn't pay attention to details and you
don't work that hard sales will work for
anybody I firmly believe that anybody
it'll work it's just most people don't
want to be disciplined and most people
don't pay attention to detail so let's
get right into the sales process so in
sales you'll typically hear no matter
what business you're in you'll go
through the flow of sales some say
there's five steps some say there's six
steps seven steps 10 steps three steps
I'm explaining six steps here to you
right now step number one is prospecting
number two is approaching contact 3 is
presentation follow-up then its referral
then it's maintaining your customer
relationship so let's get right through
it and you need to ask yourself in which
of these areas you struggle so let's
start off with the first one first one
is what prospecting so what is
prospecting so prospecting a lot of
times you know people will think
prospecting is going out there in the
cold market and trying to get somebody
to buy a house from you and I'm
I'm at a mall or prospecting is me going
out there in the cold market and trying
to get somebody to you know buy my
technology from me for their company
that's prospecting no prospecting is
multiple different ways of prospecting
and I'm going to explain every single
one of these prospecting to you extreme
lien depth so you ask yourself which one
you're very good at so think about it
first of all there's really three
different types of people in the world
of prospecting that you know one is
people you don't know
two is people you know and threes people
your people know again people you don't
know
coal market okay people you know this is
your warm market three people your
people know which for me it's my
favorite market because there's nothing
like getting into this market now from
the lowest to the highest the lowest
percentage of conversion is people you
don't know
then it's people your people know then
it's people you know sometimes this is
harder than this one value but stay with
me here so okay so Pat great now I know
what my market is excellent so how do I
now get a market no problem you got to
look at prospecting as multiple
different ways of catching a fish so you
can't just have one way of doing it you
need to have multiple different Nets out
there and one of them is generally going
to work with you pick any product I
don't care what product it is to pick
any any product you're selling you can
you can figure out ways to get it to
other markets how can you do that one is
social media one outlet is social media
there's a lot of people doing that you
can do it on YouTube Facebook Twitter
you can do sponsored post boost them you
can do Instagram posts and boosts that
you can do YouTube Google AdWords
there's so many things you can do on
social media the other one on people you
don't know is networking events you can
go to networking event especially the
area of networking events that's
predicated to the product that you're
mainly marketing so whatever you're
networking the man you want to go to
that people are dying did a video on it
last week what was a video color we did
last week it was called the how to charm
like Casanova in that video how to charm
like Casanova I talked about
eighteen different ways to master the
art of networking if you have a watched
a video go watch your video it's one the
previous episode so how do you become a
better network and one is networking
meant another one is going into coal
market prospecting you just meet people
randomly and you approach them and you
have a script prospecting another one
maybe friendship a farming you're
turning strangers into friends so I
don't know John but I keep going to this
restaurant and eventually John and I
become best friends because we have
lunch at 12 o'clock and every day we
talk sports six weeks from now we've had
four beers together and I already know
his life stories family I just don't
they what kind of business are you and
that relationship went from being a cold
relationship to now warm tonight we went
golfing together we have a friendship
now our wives have met each other
whatever I know his kids I've met his
parents I met his girlfriend I met her
you know boyfriend we're good we'll get
along there is a relationship there so
strangers into friends that's a whole
different video by itself then there is
a friendship a departments of people
that your people know I love this part
with referrals on prospecting is because
I'm gonna get back to him referrals but
on the prospecting side on who my people
know they make for the best prospects on
when I ask them specifically what kind
of clients I'm looking at so then their
center of influence what center of
influence center of influence for me and
prospecting is you taking the top 20
people you respect the most in your
community make the list of it top 20
community make a list of it then you
know what I want you to do I want you to
contact these 20 people and ask him to
go have a cup of coffee with you what's
the script sounds like like this hey I
really value the fact that you're a
successful entrepreneur one day I'm
planning on being someone like you I
would love to treat you to coffee one of
these days or lunch when it's a good
time for us to god it's on me I just
want 30 minutes of your time no problem
then you go and you're simply building a
relationship eventually three six twelve
months later you give whatever you can
to them they're going to give back to
you how can I help you they'll give you
the context or relationship that they
have that could help you right and so
then that needs to be maintained
constantly so there's a different
different ways to improve in a
prospecting site now let's continuous
I'm going to come back to prospecting
approaching contact what's approaching
contact well one could be how you send
your formal email to somebody to follow
up with them once you got the info so I
got the number I got the phone number I
got the email address I got first name
last name then what do I do step number
two i befriend them on LinkedIn then on
LinkedIn I sent him a message or if I
already have their email I send him an
email and I say hey it was a pleasure
meeting you earlier today you know I was
impressed with that I'd love for us to
schedule time to visit and talk about
pop pop I think there's ways we can
create a synergistic relationship here
great so that's the approach in contact
what is that script that you have for
this then there's a phone call script
what script you have I mean I can tell
you I saw Valley's memberships back in
1999 that was what 17 years ago we're
talking about I know the script till
today here's what the script sound like
so somebody calls in and it would call
it a telephone inquiry they put on hold
I would say TI line one you would pick
up thank you for them how may I help you
yes I'm calling you're more information
about a gym no problem you call that a
great time by coming in today you can
get started as low as five dollars down
and a monthly membership would only
break down to be a few dollar five s six
to eight dollars a week by the way what
are some of your fitness goals are you
trying to lose weight tone up or
increase energy I want to increase
energy are you currently working out at
a gym
I'm not what is your current routine how
far do you live from here etc etc let me
give you a virtual tour of what our gym
looks like that's exactly the script and
then it would go into schedule time for
you to come in it was a script it worked
now obviously most people sound like
scripts look my body and your body is
made up of skeletons that's generally
the same okay you may have longer legs
you may have shorter legs you may have
bigger feet smaller feet you may have
bigger hands smaller hand bigger torso
you know wider shoulders smaller head
bigger head skin it doesn't matter this
skeleton is generally the same it's the
body and the skin outside that may be a
little bit different you need to you
need a script and then from there you
can add your personality to it but there
needs to be a scripture do you have a
script or you're approaching
once you get this in email Facebook
Linked and called do you have that if
you don't that is a leak you need to
have that three presentation so a lot of
times believe it or not out of all these
things you know what's the one thing
most people are very very good at is
presentation why it's the easiest one
anybody can present it's so easy to
present oh I mean I know everything
about our presentation but how come I'm
not making a lot of money because this
doesn't make you money
this doesn't make you money this is very
easy to do this doesn't mean you don't
need to be good at this this is very
important but it's the easiest one to do
it ain't that hard to learn how to give
the presentation so what are some leaks
on presentations that you'll generally
see oh my gosh if you catch yourself in
a presentation it's a sit-down with a
business owner it's a sit-down with a
client at the kitchen table it's a
sit-down with them come into your office
it's a sit-down with a product you're
selling it's you know furniture and they
want to furnish your house whatever it
is if it's a lot of talk talk talk talk
talk talk talk no one cares you've lost
them okay
I would watch people's presentation
carriers would come and they would say
hey let me tell you about the history of
our company and I specifically said look
I just want you to know you've been on
since 1886 I'm very impressed
what are we going to do here here's what
we're looking for no problem so don't be
the person that goes for 17 minutes you
know the history of our company first 30
seconds maybe seven minutes too long
brief it's all about a good presenter is
very good at asking questions so tell me
what's what's important to you what's
important to that what do you think
about this what do you think about that
how about this part what do you think
about that what do you think about this
is this important you how do you feel
about it how do they feel about it how
does your wife feel about it how do your
customers feel about it is that
something that's important to between 0
to 10 what would you say this it's
questions that you're asking on the
presentation if it's too many statements
without questions you're not a good
presenter a good presenter somebody
that's also asking questions because
you're getting to find out about who
them sales is so simple sales is so easy
if you simply looked at the customers as
you this is how I like to sell I look at
you as the customer and I ask myself if
I were you what would I buy and what
would serve you if I'm you and so I said
look if I were you I would need this
this this based on this this this that
you told me and I would need a little
bit of this this this based on that said
it showed me even though you have this
right now you're paying this much for it
right now I don't think you have a need
for because you told me this this this
so here's what I propose we do I said we
start with this we start with this you
can drop this and that's good for
starters and twelve months from now
let's revisit to see what we can do what
do you think about that great any
questions no let's go to paperwork start
very simple right presentation is
questions and knowing your craft knowing
your product and generally not be as
some people when you don't know what
you're talking about Nexus follow-up
okay remember how I said two things is
the reason why people don't make money
in cells what was one of them discipline
here's what this is 100% discipline
there's this is nothing more than
discipline it's nothing more than
discipline I talked to you about the
other D which was what details so why is
discipline and details important here
well d tells us very important because
if you're following up with me as a
customer and you don't remember our
conversations details that we had the
first time it tells me you don't pay
attention to things you're just trying
to get the money okay but if you do have
the discipline to follow up and you do
remember the specific details of what I
told you the first time you and I had a
seven minute conversation I'm very
impressed
you value my time I'll do business with
you because it's details and it's
discipline make sense so follow up the
biggest sales the biggest Commission
checks the most profitable opportunities
that I've had in my career as an
entrepreneur typically happened after I
reached out to the customer or the
person I don't know seven eight nine ten
times I mean God knows how many times I
reached out to certain people before I
made this sell because it was followed
but here's what I did know I had very
simple scripts that I would use when I
leave a phone call this is what my call
would sound like I would say hey John
Patrick right now is not a good time I'm
just really not interested right now at
this phase of my life that thought that
thought perfect there's two ways I can
react to that I'm rejected or my other
question is what um John would you mind
if I file
load up with you six months from now
maybe in somewhere around February would
that be okay with you you know a Patrick
that's not a problem
excellent well listen John since I'm not
going to talk to you between now and
then happy Halloween happy Thanksgiving
and Happy Holidays and I'll talk to you
in February hopefully before Valentine's
Day so I'll be able to wish you happy
Valentine's it I like your attitude
Patrick okay take care John I'll talk to
you in February bye bye
make a note at details of what to bring
up daughter son family friends etc etc
you add the details then you call in
February in February if they don't pick
up here's how I leave a message
John this is Patrick giving you call
again I haven't spoken to you since
August happy Halloween Happy
Thanksgiving
happy holidays Happy New Year and I'm
hoping I can wish you a happy
Valentine's Day because it's a week away
from now but look I know you had a thing
going on with your daughter in November
her wedding was coming I just wanted to
call you I'm sure you thought I forgot
about you haven't forgot about you I'm
looking forward to seeing it this is a
good time for us to do something
something special you just come up with
what we offer right now with our
products I love to tell you more about
it what's the best time for us to call
here's my phone number again I thought
that that up but I left a message
whether he calls me back or not it's
irrelevant disappoint details he's
impressed then I'm going to call him
again two to four weeks later until I
get a hold of him then again if he tells
me not interested John would you mind if
I called you six months from now not at
all Patrick great I will call you in
August so between now and day now and
then guess what that that I know this
sounds some of you may be listening to
this and oh my gosh Pat are you really
like this yes because this works sales
is so easy my gosh this is absolutely I
am amazed when some people are not
making a quarter million dollars
yourself and this is the easiest thing
you'll ever do but if details and
discipline is really what it's all about
so follow up next referrals what's
referral so a lot of times think about
it this way a lot of times you know in
sports you ever seen when you know one
of these guys shoots the basket like a
Nick Young I don't know if you guys are
Nicky
guess he played for the Lakers I don't
know why the Lakers ever sign of its
because there was nobody on the league
for them to sign but they signed Niq Niq
young okay um so he's got a decent shot
so there's this one time of the game he
shoots the three-pointer and he turns
around like that has walking away that
he's so confident guess what the three
is going to go it doesn't go in he
looked like a fool it was an ESPN
highlight run if you go on YouTube and
type and Nick young mystery pointer turn
around you'll see the video it's so
embarrassing some salespeople are like
that they go in and they close the deal
I've got the signature everything man
this is so cool and they walk out and
they forget man you just made $2,000
there's like $100,000 here what are you
doing
stay relaxed don't celebrate the game's
not over yet you still got to play
defense refroze is what keeps you in
business that's your defense so I got to
figure out a way to get referrals so
then the Knicks Malik is referrals how
many referrals do average per client how
do you ask for referrals what is your
referral script you have a referral
script when you ask it do you prepare
them or do all of a sudden say surprise
I want referrals or do you say in your
presentation Jon I hope you understand
you know the way I make my living I
don't earn salary I simply make a living
based on referrals so referrals is my
main source of keeping me in business
and I hope that I earn your trust to the
point where you're comfortable maybe
later on we meet or later on in the
presentation if you feel good about what
I have to offer to you you're
comfortable giving me referrals right if
it makes sense yeah of course sure you
agree no problem boom then at that
presentation I say hey you remember when
I told you earlier last time we were
together that my business was purely on
referrals but and I said if it made
sense and obviously we're doing business
together so you know who do you know
that dot dot dot dot dot and yes for
referrals
piece of cake but don't don't be a Nick
Young telling you right now don't be a
Nick Young shooting the three-pointer
excited come back around and play
defense you're about to lose the game
defense wins championships come back
Denver Broncos won a championship last
year not because Peyton Manning wasn't
having his best season they won't
because the defense was one the greatest
ever referrals and last one
now what's last one man the last one is
so important man the last one is so
important
but it's it's boring okay so let me let
me explain to you why it's boring okay
so think about it this way I mean I'm
gonna use this analogy because it's
effective you know a lot of times you
know we want new things we want a new
girlfriend it's kind of cool man a new
girlfriend a new boyfriend a new you
know new no no everything is new I want
to new it love okay and then what we
don't realize is you know the most
powerful things that have ever been
built we want a new industry to new
product to sell it's so exciting the
most powerful people in the world
salespeople businesspeople leaders
influential they generally chose one
route and they stuck to it and they
maintained that industry that
relationship so maintaining your
customer relationship this is when
you're going to you know st. status type
of figure if you know how to maintain
relationships what do I mean by
maintaining relationship to me you know
I love to maintain people that stay with
me for a very long time strong team is
very important to me so my job is to
make sure the company's doing very good
my job is to make sure that environment
is a great environment my job is to make
sure everybody's grown we're developing
outgrown everybody cuz I'm leading them
at the front my job is to make sure
there's an edge going on and we're
competing we're growing everyone's
coming up with ideas why because I want
to maintain relation with home office
with my carriers with my vendors we
might you know following with you I mean
we want to have an edge because we want
to build a YouTube channel we believe
pound for pound we can go against
anybody on YouTube you see a lot of
channels on YouTube that are purely
motivation motivation motivation
regurgitating regurgitating
regurgitating regurgitating same message
over and over and over again people
finally say like you keep saying the
same thing we don't want to be that
channel we want to have a million subs
on YouTube because we have plans of what
we want to do to influence people around
the world to make a decision to realize
happiness is linked to being an
entrepreneur because you create you're
part of a community and it's just kind
of cool to have some kind of an
ownership of what you're doing there's a
certain sense of excitement that comes
from that so I want to help more people
become entrepreneurs whatever you're
doing this is what matters
matter to me you're important to me I
listen to you I got an email I got a
letter here I get gifts all the time and
if I talked about the amount of gifts
that I get I'd be here for a long time
but now I get a lot of people that also
sympatric I want to take you out to
lunch I want to take you out to coffee I
don't have time to say that to everybody
it's very uh grateful for the messages
don't get me wrong but I just don't have
the time do any of that stuff right now
I got three kids my traveling is hectic
I'm running a company we got a lot of
things going on but I was very impressed
with this letter I got from an attorney
from New York and I'll read it to you
and I'll give him some love with his
first name and then I'll tell you the
approach he took this to me is
impressive this is a prime example we
get fan mail all the time all the time
we get people that stop by and visit and
they'll say Pat I'm in town you have to
say yes I just want to meet you for five
minutes and shake your hands great
they'll come up I'll shake hands as long
as nothing is too creepy great well
meeting we get some random strange
things that happen here and we got a lot
of guards and all that stuff to make
sure we protect it but I was so
impressed by this letter and so he's an
attorney out of New York John I will
give you a love John and you know who
you are it's a law firm out of New York
papapapa a story of New York is where
he's out of so John if you're watching
this you know exactly what this is I
want to read it to you I want to read
you his letter and he's got two cigars
here for me and this is not a regular
cigar he send me nice I want to say it's
Sifuentes I think it is red is that what
it is
ah yes when says yeah it's a font a
cigar okay good so it's decent cigar
nice cigar thank you John
here's how the letter sounds like I have
been watching your youtube channel for a
few weeks and yes I subscribe thank you
for the stop I've been frequenting to
watch various speakers over the years
and were they were they were simply
there you however were presented and you
made me present you were able to grab my
attention and hold it it was so much
your words or your plethora of books on
the wall but it was your energy and your
voice isn't annoying family consensus
well I appreciate your family consensus
apparently somebody said the other that
can listen to his voice he sounds like a
porn star which I've never been called a
porn star before for
my voice I don't even know what a
pornstar sound sounds like but
apparently I have the boys okay now
don't get distracted come back I want to
continue with the letter and then he
says I now mostly watch your videos with
my wife and children as you I work with
my wife and I believe we equally shared
a belief that we aren't simply parents
but responsible for assuring our
children our leaders are not cattle
towards the end in addition to other
books I make sure to my eldest child ten
years old read certain books so that he
may have the opportunity to understand
in an early age trials and tribulation
that he will face in life as he journeys
to fulfill his dreams instilling in him
I hope the belief that he can accomplish
his goals through helping others
providing them emphasizing that others
will perceive must perceive the value or
there is none a few books that he's read
I recommended following books or they're
plenty of dr. Seuss or Bob Berg good
book to go Giver The Alchemist Paulo
color what books would you recommend
what prompted this correspondence was
your video on how to work with family I
watch it online my family and found them
myself thinking about the next I share
your belief in practice as well with my
wife but near the end where you discuss
how you would handle your children at
the workplace or potential business
venture resonated and impacted upon me
your dedication and discipline your
content offers value to our family and
as a small talk listen to this watch
this and as a small token of my
appreciation I offer an open invitation
any time you're in New York City to join
me for fresh-squeezed juice he watches
the regular watcher so he knows right
now have lost 17 pounds since you don't
drink coffee I don't drink coffee
sounds good lunch or dinner would be
fine perhaps you can challenge me to
find a great spot for liver interesting
John if you like liver man we got to go
to some Mediterranean place I just got
to tell them how to make it I am
enclosing two cigars one for each of us
hoping you will save them until we have
our encounter I would enjoy the
opportunity to meet signature a wet
signature the close cigars are short not
because I want to limit our time
together but because I value your time
listen man I got to tell you I mean you
are pretty much an example of how to do
this part and you know this is class I
like this I wanted to give John some
long
so John if you wanted to slow is that it
to you with your last time you can
comment on the bottom it's all good with
me if you don't I'm giving your love for
what you did I'm impressed by that that
tells me he probably treats his
customers that way and he maintains
customer relationships see the world of
business and attorney is a salesperson
because you're selling people a CPA is a
salesperson and accountant is a cell a
dentist's a great dentist that makes a
lot of money I know solid dentist in LA
who make two three hundred grand a month
but their salespeople I want the other
thing I was test driving a Lamborghini
the guy comes with a Porsche and he
bought a brand new Aventador and I said
hey what do you do says I'm a dentist
how do you make 200 grand a month as a
dentist well he makes to another grand
I'm one because he's a businessman and a
salesperson on getting other people's
business but I guarantee there's some of
this going on without this you're gonna
go to the top very simple because they
talk to one another
you got to learn how to treat them very
good so again ask as you look at this
people often ask me well Pat based on
your opinion which one do you think is
the most important which one is the most
important well let me tell you which one
without it nothing exists if you don't
do this kiss-up goodbye
you know what's crazy you know it's
crazy
Michaelangelo kind of time do I have
like three minutes okay you know it's
crazy what's crazy is some of you who
are watching this you are incredible at
this but you are so frightened of this
because of that you'll never make you
big unless if you face your fears here
and start doing this in this because you
know where the money is at the money is
here you know where the guarantee is
that we guarantees here this guarantees
you this means nothing very little news
some but not the most this is what's
most important anytime as always tell
people if your phone doesn't run out of
batteries twice a day you ain't working
hard enough your phones gotta run about
it batteries twice a day not because
you're playing tell me some of the games
that people play on the phones
Michelangelo what would you say Angry
Birds what else what's the one thing the
war game the war
game that people play clash of clans
clash of clans right or some of these
things that people play right okay your
phone should be running out of batteries
twice a day because you're making 200
calls a day okay if your rookie
entrepreneur you a mechanic also that
you have really hungry you're just kind
of winging it you're hoping this thing
works out where you get lucky there's a
guaranteed formula to this so with that
being said would that being said one if
you got any questions or comments about
this comment on the bottom two if you
haven't subscribed to the channel
Michaelangelo throw me my favorite towel
two of my favorite pillow to your left
I need your help I need you to subscribe
help us get to 100,000 share our content
with other people you know we've been
growing very fast the last couple months
your YouTube channel has which is quite
exciting but our goal is to get to a
million our short term goals get to a
hundred thousand subs on entrepreneurs
to learn more about the contents here
again subscribe if you haven't it n what
else if you watch this video on a
complete different website you can
always come back to paps bedevi comm
boom and get all the content we offer
for entrepreneurship with that being
said thank you so much for watching
take care alight
you